michael irvin heard the bells of his
phone ringing he was the rich eyes and
show calling him up how are you rich
being in the room being in a room with
him doing negotiations and he's telling
all of these stories I'm like can we
just get my money please but that's
exactly what he does you can't help but
laugh I love it's great how are you all
it's great and suppose who didn't see it
it seemed like he was about to lace the
story with the word his father actually
used before saying the word bells and it
looked like it would start with an F I
mean this guy is just a first-rate
storyteller and entertainer which is why
it's kind of killing him that he's
probably out of the playoffs when
everybody's paying attention to what you
think of the McCarthy higher or what do
you think okay you know it wasn't a WoW
me higher but it wasn't a what are you
serious kind of higher when you were
dropping that yeah they think about
hiring wit and I was like what what are
you talking about so it wasn't that but
then when I watched the press conference
in and I saw Michael Carson in a
different way when I watched the press
conference you know I thought he was
trying to be open and trying to be
honest and talking about his own
deficiencies and and working on
shortcomings because when you leave
Green Bay and Anna Rodgers saying you're
a little rigid and antiquated basically
and then you come in you're like wow
what were we getting here but but I
thought he did a pretty good job in that
press conference talking about how he's
trying to learn in that year off and get
better at this job so so he wanted me
over in the press conference I mean see
what happens now well the question is
again and you know I had I had Troy on
the day that so now I've got two
triplets to discuss that Troy was on the
about the first hour that McCarthy and
the news had broken that he was a coach
is just what what do you think could be
different and whatever else he brings
from the Green Bay system that
Aaron Rodgers succeeded in for some time
what what do you think from that would
actually work with dak and Zeke and
presumably Amari Cooper should he stay
one thing the more thing I think you
know in this situation is you have
talented guys and-and-and and now they
know that their leader has actually laid
someone or something to a Super Bowl and
won the Super Bowl is there so adage how
can I tell you what I do not know how
can I take you where I did not go well
he did go there so now you can you know
people get a report talking about what
he brings from fear into these guys fear
is gone you guys can stop that fear is
gone because that degree you're not
talking about bringing fear to the top
guys to doc Prescott DQ always autumn re
Cooper's all the old guys those guys
contracts are in the front office
because they're going to be making so
much money guarantee this can you get
them to build a reverence for you
can they respect you can they look at
you and want to be the best that they
can be see you deep down inside and
bring the best out of them that is what
that is the key I think for my McCarthy
and I thought it needed to be a guy with
raw Ryan him I watched it Matt and that
rule interview a press conference and I
thought yes rock rock videos brought
Rajyam but but the reality is you can
get there in other ways you can get
there in other ways and having that
Super Bowl carried out the other thing
was the guys listen I've been here I
want a Super Bowl right here in Dallas
all we have to do is these certain
things and we can be back we can be in a
Super Bowl I think that carries big
weight Michael Irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show ok so check that BOTS I guess
that that's done with Dallas and that
leaves the Browns what do you think they
mean if if you could choose somebody
that you're either here and that's out
there or not I mean what do you think
the Cleveland Browns need for for for
Baker and that and that squad O'Dell and
everybody that that
be inheriting the new coach what do you
think like and and and I think they have
you know they have some great talent on
that team to like that I think it's he
needs a little more direction you know
I'm probably a better approach honestly
I have free kitchens you know was was
more of a friend to Baker being a
guidance for Baker you know and he came
in trying to throw the ball more when I
think should have been League on the run
game and then I allowed the passing game
just spread there was a maturation
process for even a great Tom Brady Tom
Brady didn't come right in throwing two
championships he came in basically
managing games making certain clays and
then as he got older and got better and
he learned more about defenses and I in
his own office then he took over look at
what they tried to do it try to make
Baker right now
that guy that's a hard process that they
need somebody to come in and say Baker I
understand your number one pick and I
understand you got all this gutsy macho
stuff going on but there's a process to
this you can't get to the prize becoming
one of the greatest doors in this game
without going through the process right
now and and I don't know what guy out
there that can come and sell that to him
right now but that's what I think they
need they need somebody that he'll buy
into it if I'm not throwing for 300
yards if I'm throwing for 210 yards but
we're winning the game and I'm making
good decisions I'll get to the place
where I'm throwing for 300 350 yards
what we're winning game pro Football
Hall of Famers Super Bowl champion three
times over my compadre from NFL gameday
morning but most importantly my great
friend Michael Irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show you know I said something
earlier on the show I got a little heat
for and by that I mean somebody tweeted
something at me that told me I was
clueless that I I feel I feel better
about the Texans chances of winning this
game in Kansas City than I felt about
their chances of beating Buffalo at home
last week and I turned to you somebody
who said you know what I see this Texans
team if will fuller comes back healthy
and they can get past this line making a
long run so I give you the floor here on
what you think about the Texans now that
what you saw last week is as fresh in
your mind Michael right and enriched you
know I give them a shot here too only if
they are healthy because here it is you
see all that deshaun Watson had to do to
win that game against Buffalo a
muffaletta very good defense but he had
to do a lot to win that ballgame and
they need easier plays and will fuller
when you get wolfwoman Kenny Stills and
you have these guys on the outside now
you get the easier place to DeAndre
Hopkins because if they try to double
him then one of those guys go over the
top and you get the big play you're
going to be they have the ability to
make the big play and they are going to
need that to fight against Kansas City
because with Nicole arcminutes already
killed those guys they can make the big
play at any point but they gotta get
down to being able to just matriculate
that ball down in the field and here
they're going to have to find a better
run game this week didn't they had
against Buffalo to have a chance at
beating Kansas City but they do have a
chance at beating Kansas City and then
there's a Saturday night game I spoke at
length with second our guest Eddie
George who I reached out to we strolled
down Titans Ravens memory lane and look
NFL's a physical game playoff football
is not for the faint of heart what the
Titans Ravens just appears to be that
that difference the maker between
playoff games and ones that you know are
just gonna be an absolute slugfest
what's it like going into a playoff game
where you know Michael it's there's a
good chance that you're gonna get
somebody with a helmet the ribs or
something like that
what's that like for you the other day
because we were taught as we talked
through this game I said this this is
what I learned a few times I did play on
wildcard Sunday in if you play wildcard
Sonny like the Titans it and I'm come I
think dudes played off football game
nope nobody on New England wanted to
tackle Derrick hearing you believe that
right they were like let's just go
I said nothing like that's it we get out
of here
nobody wanted to try for that you did
anymore it's so hard don't man to turn
around when you put a physical game like
that and then the turn around and get
back up to play another physical game
because Baltimore's a physical football
team so they're going to need I think
Tennessee as great as Derrick Henry is
but I'm Tennessee I'm coming in this
game trying to get an early big play
each time I played on wildcard weekend I
wanted us to get an early big play early
in the game the division around to get
everybody hyped and get them going again
adrenaline pumping again because the
team that's at home they are so height
and they are rested
you've been banged up because you play
such a high game and you play at such
high intensity in that wild-card round
I'm looking for them to do something
with AJ Brown early to try to get early
it big play early and then shuttle back
and let Derrick Henry crush you and I
also think everything hinges on what's
going on with Mark Ingram I don't care
what you guys say everybody said what
you will Mark Ingram brings a different
taste to that football team the
Baltimore region but what about when you
played what was the most physical team
you played in the playoffs ever were you
knew going in that week like okay I I
need to make sure my head's a little bit
more on a swivel this week which one was
that for you well we play when we play
Chile Chilean in the playoffs now in it
all those games were tough I may have
called one pass in that game good wit
but there botticella was help over top
of one pass I knew this was going to be
a battle this was going to be a battle
and it battle really comes you know for
me I'm a wide receiver physically the
physical needs for me it's going to
build on and make its limited basis but
the physical needs for those offense and
defensive linemen right oh my god with
those guys going at it like that and it
was much of you too much they pound the
ball last week in Tennessee that's going
to be an incredible incredible battle
for Tennessee to get back up and match
those guys in Baltimore there wasn't
that time against seehorn Irv wasn't
that searing game
oh my god no I know we talked about that
I will say this he was trying to be
especially when they had a safety
overtopping i won't i won't buy my say
no you know the only reason you trying
to be that physical it's because you got
help back there you you could you can
dive all into my body because you know
if you miss you got a sink over there to
help you out you know i would like to
see it without their safety he said my
company exterior he would always be
quasi michael playing the dishes the
coach call on the rich guys go michael
irvin what about the fact that the
Niners have many of them haven't done it
before obviously Shanahan's coached in
it john Lynch is played and won in it
you know that's upstairs general manager
ship Sherman's done it they had at
Emanuel Sanders midseason that's been
something but the rest of them have
never played in the playoff game pretty
much how much do you put in stock into
that and the Vikings team that is coming
off of as you pointed out a shorter week
just six days removed from beating New
Orleans like that Michael and I would
put more stock into the experience
factor if if the 49ers didn't go through
that country that they went through
towards the end of the season I've been
talking about has everybody said I don't
know about the 49ers look at what they
went through us yeah look at what they
went through that is it things that you
Bri had wanted best month ever in the
history of the game in December and then
he turns around and lose that game lose
the playoff game the 49ers went to a
gauntlet of reef of teams they had to
play all of them were great games to I
mean they played every game hard I think
that carryover carries them through you
know when you start talking about
numbers over they are battle tested and
ready for this type of situation even
though they're limited in the experience
Department that's the poll question of
ER before we send him unto his good
Metroplex day Christopher go for it
which road team this weekend best chance
to pull the upset
Seahawks Vikings Titans Texans
well III that's a great poll question I
talked to somebody else about there and
I put it in this order
I do think Tennessee has a good chance
to go at pulling that upset I really do
I like Tennessee I will go probably
Tennessee in their first
maybe maybe Minnesota second I in Texas
third in actually Seattle for you like
the Packers on earth I am taking the
Packers something they lost so much
today running their run game and in the
thing that always make Russel Wilson so
tough to beat and this is why he's oh
and three of the Lambo what makes him
tough to beat cuz if you give him the
ball last you he's going to come down
and make a play well who do you think
it's just as good if not better and if
you give him the ball and right Aaron
Rodgers yes Aaron Rodgers and that's
what makes era and Rodgers actually
loves getting the ball laugh and coming
back and winning football games that's
why I give them luige all right earth
thanks for the call why do you think so
many people enjoyed watching you choose
the obvious teams for lock of the week
on NFL game in morning all season long
and then prematurely received the trophy
only to not win the title of lock of the
week by yourself because Ron Fitzpatrick
unlocked your line week in week 17 why
do you think people enjoyed all that is
it because I got so pissed all about it
what do you think somebody up greatly be
greatly low that picture you posted yes
hold it all when I'm looking at the
trophy and you're like what's up I'm
screaming in the foreground you're in
the background with your trophy
celebrating it Kurtz laughing and mooch
is eating that was the photograph right
perfect
that is our family
right love Europe thanks to the call
I'll see you at the meeting tomorrow
I'll see you at the meeting tomorrow
love you too but no safe or without meds
for everybody what's up buddy four more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app